[Music]
i rule
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos and today
um we're going to give you a little bit
of my comic book history
and we're going to go a little bit
deeper
into what i call the budget line
of statures so without further ado
i give you the comic book accurate
1 10th scale battle door aroma series 5
iron studios incredible hulk
now growing up as a child all i would do
is read incredible hulk books i i i love
the fact that you know he was strong
without having to you know
show it he was the strongest one there
was he only wanted to be left alone
and thunderbolt ross always was
on his trail 100 of the time
trying to bring the incredible hulk in
every episode every comic book
this guy was on the hulk
and lost every time
now there's other things that include
thunderbolt ross
did later the general of the army
that uh tried to put them on equal
playing fields with the incredible hulk
i guess if you can't beat them
you join them right but
to get back to incredible hulk um i
always
thought that the contrast between the
purple
and the green was fantastic always
it was just simplicity it was strength
it was poetry emotion
every book from sal buscema which is my
favorite artist of the incredible hulk
showed the rampaging hulk the incredible
hulk the savage hawk
the the mindless hawk the hulk that
was you know that didn't speak in full
sentences
you know that incredible hulk is the
hulk
that i love so when i saw the statue
come up
i said you know what i'm gonna get this
comic accurate hope
even though i have a ton of hulk i
definitely needed this in
my stable also the fact that
you don't have to go and break the bank
to enjoy
your hobbies this one cost 165 dollars
you know plus shipping from sideshow
and i found it utterly amazing
the level of detail on the statue is
incredible
uh it's it's it looks like it's loosely
based off
english uh hulk movie
that failed movie i i didn't like that
movie but again
i'm appreciative for any comic book uh
movie that comes out about characters
that i grew up with and that i love
so i looked at it i saw the similarities
in the 3d models that they used for the
movies
uh and this character
so you know i still went with it even
though i really didn't like the movie
that much
but i appreciate the movie for giving it
that effort
they did change a little things about
the incredible hulk
know their incredible hulk doesn't get
madder and get bigger
you know that doesn't happen he's the
same height he just gets stronger
and i guess he couldn't convey that
inside the movie with the script that he
was given
and later on i was told that his father
was supposed to be the absorbing man
movie total fail in my opinion still
appreciate it
but the statue the statue depicts a
scene
to me when he's in san francisco
and he has the dirt on him and
uh when the army is attacking him
and if you look at the statue he has the
dirt on his hands
he has the fire hydrant in the city the
base is uh meticulously done with the
details of the rock
and then you can see under the base of
the rock where the hulk broke the ground
fantastic level of detail for one temp
scale
this is what i'm talking about when i
say that youtube can
you know become the king of statues when
you purchase and enjoy your hobbies
you can put them up in smaller spaces
let's say you don't have a ton of space
this statue
fits in that space that 110 scale you
know and i and i
have a ton of them because i have spaces
for them you know they're definitely
needed
they should be appreciated and a lot of
uh statue collectors
don't cover this stuff i love them i
love the fact that everyone can enjoy in
this great hobby in this great community
just as myself so you can go to the
higher scale or you can go to the lower
scale
now one thing about this statue when it
came
it didn't sit flush in the base
the peg was a little bit off and from
the pictures here
you can see it doesn't sit right all the
way in
it's snug it won't move but it's not as
flush as i would like it i would like
his feet to completely
be flush on the ground flat and
that's what i was looking for but this
is the part of the video
where i would tell you to like follow
and subscribe and also
go to lordsofgaming.net where we have
the dimensions of the statue we have a
ton of opinion pieces
we have a whole slew of writers
putting up incredible stuff right now
streets of rage four is going up
uh rage is doing that uh that review on
that
incredible stuff incredible stuff
that's happening at loads of gaming.net
and also
go watch the last word with law cognito
and ibontas
destiny games is going on right now
my warlocks are in i think trailing
i think the hunters won the first day
i didn't like that or was it the titans
i know it wasn't a
warlock but definitely want to get
revenge so
get on destiny follow uh the last word
of lord cognito and ivantis so you can
be up
on all the destiny information and also
while you're here hit that join button
hit that joy
button it's down at the bottom so all
you got to do is go right there
hit that join button and make sure that
you follow the realm so you can see
all the videos of everything that's in
the background that not everybody gets a
chance to see
stick around watch the unboxing of this
statue
and listen to some good music without
this guy talking
until next week when i bring you
another incredible statue
stay collected
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
i'm doing going going crazy
i'm going going crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
i'm going going going crazy
i'm going going crazy
[Music]
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
i'm going going crazy
[Music]
i'm going going going crazy
i'm going going
[Music]
crazy crazy i'm going going crazy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
going crazy
i'm going going going crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm going going going crazy
i'm going going
[Music]
i'm going going going crazy
yeah i'm going going going crazy
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
i'm going going crazy
i'm going going crazy
[Music]
you